tiens d'ailleurs j'ai envie vous avez un
coup de griffe j'ai un coup de griffe
oui contre qu'avec autres disent
toujours disney c'est magique etc
ils ont appliqué des règles de
confinement sa part d'une bonne
intention mais la magie elle est où
maintenant sert qu'on ne pourra plus
prendre dans les bras milk est assez
normal avec le move mais michael est un
masque j en suis alors est là et vous
êtes contents vous vivez dans un monde
d'enfants y avait il ya plus de
spectacle
il ya plus de parades les effigies les
personnages apparaissent plus et bien
son auteur je peux juste vous poser une
question est vraiment de vous ce couple
est alors d'autant que la mairie thémis
s'appelait il est pas vraiment de moi
mais ils auraient pu être deux mois à ce
qu'on l'a soufflé g 10 jean moulin sont
d'accord c'est le cas dit qu'ils
voulaient a soufflé jeu de la vérité
pour les téléspecteurs la ghréline et
nous suivons directs n'ont fait que du
chi kelly c'est vous qui l'avez donne à
jean michel bats je vais sanctionner des
deux ça ça peut dénoncer vous dire ma
vérité h présence nacho merci de
souvenirs oui j'ai eu un coup de fil à
la production oui quel pas l'avouer
monde y est ce que tu veux faire un coup
de griffe contre disney j'ai dit non je
trouve que c'est très bien ce qu'ils ont
fait non je vous donne donc parfait nous
allons donner à jean mi il le fera voilà
comment ça s'est passé cyril merci de
nagano mondiaux a dit alors à moi j'ai
envie de dire à jean-michel est-ce que
c'est grave parce que c'est vrai que de
nos jours maintenant quand on va à
disney ah oui effectivement mickey c'est
la mascotte mais moi personnellement
pour avoir deux enfants une fille de 10
ans elle y va vraiment pour les
princesses et un petit garçon de 5 ans
effectivement mon fils si les baous pour
les super héros ou pour star wars
donc après j'ai eu la chance moi
effectivement en 92 à l'époque de faire
l'ouverture de disney et là ça aurait
été malheureux face aurait été très
triste de nombreux signes d'émotion la
pâte pour faire des selphy que les
personnages mais ne faire des photos
alors le recteur il ya des apprenants
regarde là j'ai des infos même si la
date est encore incertaine le parc
d'attraction disneyland paris va rouvrir
ses portes au public
mais le groupe américain n'a pas
l'intention de prendre le moindre risque
les équipes du parcours en effet rédigé
un cahier des charges de 214 pages
détaillant point par point la manière
d'opérer cette réouverture et que les
visiteurs se rassurent les mesures
sanitaires seront prises très au sérieux
ainsi tous les visiteurs à partir de 9
ans seront dans l'obligation de porter
un masque les shows dont la fameuse
parade du parc seront suspendus mais
plus grave encore les enfants n'auront
plus le droit de faire des câlins à
mickey en effet par mesure de sécurité
les personnages du parc ne pourront plus
entrer en contact direct avec les
enfants il faudra donc attendre la fin
de cette crise sanitaire pour pouvoir
enfin serrer à nouveau ces quatre doigts
boudinés et se blottir contre son ventre
mois le voilà alors c'est vrai bon voila
moi je trouve que l'or là je vous dire
un coup de griffe contre disney là je ne
comprends pas moi ya pas de coups de
griffes c'est complètement normal c'est
bien soit non mais là c'est n'importe
quoi là franchement oui matin qu'un dock
sur dix ne changeait plus rien à voir
avec mais ça effectivement tu as droit
encore et qui est personne ne sait plus
calmement mais irait ouvre effectivement
et prennent la température voilà et puis
ensuite sur un petit peu moins de monde
dedans et pour protéger les enfants et
les parents n'y a pas de parade pour
éviter que les gens se massent c'est
effectivement y'a pas les ja pas l'ailé
on peut pas faire des photos avec les
avec des personnages en faudra aussi
pour que les gens fassent pas la queue
éviter qui se passe on est en train de
prendre des précautions pour que les
enfants et les parents
depuis sa chute à clé sans être malade
et non est un vieux con comme toi karim
et qui dit damien perquis élaguer soit
malade
les primaires c'est mon ami arrêtons le
respecte on peut avoir un ami qui dit
des bêtises mais là il donne son avis et
tous les habits sont les bienvenus jean
michel a donné son avis le rabot et son
désir et ça me fait extrêmement plaisir
mais c'est pas parce qu'on donne son
avis qu'on est plus con qu'un autre voie
là bas sauf vous l'aviez qu'on voit là
bas non bye bye mais il faut être con
pour une conne comme toi
au sommet où il faut être con pour vous
mais pas con pour jour non en fait il
est censé manon mais la vraie question
qui sait que envie d'embrasser mickey il
put il s'en rend pas et qu'on sa famille
qu'on a c'est qu'on nous mêmes le mic
équipe idéale